un bon trois ans nadège une semaine
encore crucial qui s'annonce sur le
front sanitaires à quoi peut-on
s'attendre confinera confinera pas c'est
la question que tout le monde se pose
alors que l'hypothèse d'un troisième
confinement se fait de plus en plus
pressante
emmanuel macron souhaite l'éviter au
maximum le chef de l'état souhaite en
effet connaître les effets du couvre-feu
à 18 heures avant de se prononcer des
effets qui devrait être visible à partir
de samedi
et pourtant un peu plus tôt dans la
journée jean castex le premier ministre
eh bien on en sait que des décisions
devront être prises cette semaine
tous ces indicateurs sont inquiétants
nous ne devons pas baisser la garde mais
amplifié la stratégie des décisions
seront à prendre cette semaine
alors face à la hausse du nombre
d'hospitalisations plus de 26000
recensés hier un record depuis le mois
de décembre face à la l'apparition de
nouveaux variants sur le sol français
un troisième confinement pourrait donc
être décrété dès samedi ou alors en
début de semaine prochaine en place et
lieu de ce couvre-feu à 18 heures
instaurée depuis depuis dix jours
maintenant dans tout l'hexagone ici
confinement il y a il devrait davantage
ressembler à celui de l'hôtel plus que
celui du printemps dernier puisque les
écoles devraient rester ouverte c'est en
tout cas ce que répète jean michel
blanquer le ministre de l'éducation
nationale le medef ainsi que
l'organisation nationale des chambres de
commerce et d'industrie appellent de
leur côté à laisser ouverts tous les
commerçants cadres confinement alors
nadège le haut conseil pour la santé
publique a publié de nouvelles
recommandations pour se protéger contre
le variant britannique du coronavirus de
quoi s'agit-il
absolument et parmi les mesures figurent
le port du masque en tissu fait maison
est désormais déconseillés puisqu'il est
jugée inefficace face au nouveau variant
du coc vide 19 il faudra donc
privilégier désormais le masque en tissu
industriel dits de catégorie 1
le masque chirurgical ou encore le ffp2
le haut conseil pour la santé publique
préconise aussi d'augmenter la
distanciation physique entre deux
personnes pour la faire passer à 2
mètres et puis lé cas contacts sont
désormais considérés comme contact à
risque l adage en ce qui concerne la
vaccination à présent c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle puisque moderna annonce
aujourd'hui que son vaccin qui fait
partie donc des deux injecté en france
et efficace contre les variants
britannique et sud africain
tout à fait en la société américaine dit
avoir obtenu des résultats satisfaisants
elle a toutefois précisé qu'elle allait
travailler à développer une dose
additionnel pour accroître la protection
face aux nouveaux variants nous sommes
encouragés par ces nouvelles données qui
renforce notre confiance dans le fait
que le vaccin de moderna contre le coc
vite 19 devrait protéger contre ces
nouveaux variants détectée mais par
précaution nous mettons à l'essai à
candidats pour un rappel contre le
variant sud africain pour déterminer
s'il serait plus efficace pour augmenter
les niveaux d'anticorps contre ce
variant et d'autres futurs variant
potentiel
et puis ce nouveau coup dur pour la
recherche en france on apprend
aujourd'hui que l'institut pasteur
renonce à développer son principal
vaccins contre eux le kobe 19 raison
invoquée il ne serait pas suffisamment
efficace contre le virus c'est en tout
cas ce qu'ont démontré les premiers
essais cliniques les réponse immunitaire
induite se sont avérées inférieures à
celles observées chez les personnes
guéri d'une infection naturelle ainsi
qu'à celles observées avec les vaccins
autorisés contre le coc vie 19 et un
autre acteur français le laboratoire
sanofi annoncé en décembre que sans
vaccins allaient prendre du retard que
qu'il ne serait pas prêt avant la fin de
l'année 2021 lui aussi en raison de
résultats moins bons qu'attendu alors
depuis le début de la campagne de
vaccination en france un million de
personnes ont été vaccinées
contrairement aux propos du ministre de
la santé olivier verrons qui a affirmé
la semaine dernière que la totalité des
français pourraient être vaccinées d'ici
la fin de l'année le président du
conseil scientifique affirme pour sa
part que seuls 40 % de la population
française pourrait être vaccinées d'ici
au mois d'août 1 faute de doses de
vaccin en nombre suffisant merci nada
j'adhère abderrazak en direct depuis
l'elysée